こんにちは
何もない日曜日肇社長です今日もあさごはんできっちりご飯でき
目を覚ますと夕方の5時
阿部時間無駄でしたわーせっかくのに十分時間無駄にしたばあっという間なちゃんと
理由があってな
昨日夜夜遅くまでゲームセンターに行ってました
そこでとんでもないものね before キャッチングしたわけですよ
こちらです
ふーん
これはねやばいでしょ町大間にぺ悪役とはこれはガチですよガチガチっぽいっちょお湯
の目安量は900ml
律ちゃんとしっかりしてるんですけどもでもおかしくねーかなペアんねー配っていまぁ
あの販売停止になってるからなんか売ってないんですよ店が販売掲示してる商品がお店
にあるかって言ったらないと
ねそんな高さそんな ufoキャッチャーんとかねさぁやっておいてやってくださ
怪しくないですかね怪しいんですよじゃーんって書いてあるけど本音だとかわかんない
んですよ
こいつが fake であっても
セニックかな本当に不安だ
わかんない
うっ
えっどれだけていきましょう朝昼食ってないからサブこの大きさ手編みでも余裕でくれ
ます偽物だったら普通に嫌なんだけど
あおいしいルカをシールジャンプレシーブだった a ちょっと不安なんだけど違うの
かな
わかんない開けます
雨と見せないでおこう
俺だけ三ます
voodoo
mar
完全にやられたわー
えっ
ガージーガー嬉しいけどね嬉しいけどね
なんかほんとにこんなバカで帰ってやっていうかこう入ってるかと思ったらそういう
わけじゃなくてペアに駅と母が2つ入ってましたでもここには2個入ってますて帰って
ないかな
これだけ見てもにか入ってるのわからなかったって俺がミスではありません see
you next in
5万字釜付の動画的にどうなんのは俺なんでもなぁ俺のせいじゃ
動画的にどうなっても俺のせいじゃないこっちはあれだちょっと他の取得はいつ食べる
かわからないからね
懐かしい
この感じですよねこれ
えっゴキブリっ
配布もうそのゴキブリが入ってたとしてもさーんのネットに情報を出すんじゃなくてさ
直接お店に言えばいい塗ってくださいッスちょっと作ってみます
この動画の訪問
メインのイベントはもう終わったんでこの先がただ俺が
エクスパックだけの動画だ
それでも良かったら見てねかもよまじ感謝感激
えっ
お部屋をつけないと
アジア亜
あったかいんだから
[音楽]
あったかくはねよし待ちます
ラウバーンバーンから水キールだよ
なのだはララなあなあ皿ぬあーやっぱこのニュースマジでこのご時世でこのペン悟空
こと自体かなり出ないですからね
できるや動画ですよはい10位で何度だペンが完成しました
最高の日曜日たい街でいただきます
[音楽]
ねぇやっぱうめーはペヤング結局月はピョンないとほしいですね
持っています
えっ
たべコレよく開いて良いで完食でございますめっちゃでかいの入ってると思ったんです
けど
g 歳の2つでも僕は嬉しいんですよ愛だけで最後まで見てくれた君たち
質問コーナーをするんでぜひこの動画この動画がツイッターではないよこの動画の
コメント欄に質問したいこと時に書いてくださいスピナこのリクエストしても何でも
書いちゃってくださいちょっとしたら
質問コーナーで使うかも知れ胸やんが美味しかった動画でした
じゃん
[音楽]
tes
ten
中野んだねラダーだよねっ